we got Sam we've been going hard in the
paint
Sam the monster triplet for we're going
on here we've been going hard in the
paint
talked about a lot of stuff you guys
cool new sneakers yeah we got these shot
the house of future House of future game
at the house the future you know I'm 50
but I look dopest don't say doe and the
best forty year old I was actually fifty
I've ever seen in my life I like your
attitude buddy but Sam you're going hard
in the paint cuz we have uh two pictures
that fan sent to us it's the actual
would you call those those are the
reward posters right where he post out
for Tupac and Biggie when they're killed
here in Los Angeles they while Tupac was
killed in Vegas because I lived in Vegas
at that time and it was a huge [ __ ]
deal and he was going to a club that
since then has like never
I think reopen look I forget the name of
it was like the area code or some [ __ ]
like that but it was his club he's
driving too and we you know I have a
podcast called tinfoil hat and we dive
into a lot of the the we we diner season
stuff yeah we call spiritual skepticism
high right spiritual Scott this is
called conspiracy theories here but the
line we you know tomato tomahto and we
looked into that and we had a guy who
put out of movies put out a couple
movies about it about who did it and you
know - you know Suge Knight's basically
came out it was the lawyer for death row
and his and Suge Knight's wife because
they were getting a divorce and was like
all this crazy stuff and and Tupac
wanted to leave death row and that was a
big reason they took him out so it was
actually Suge Knight then who wasn't but
who didn't know [ __ ] Mike's wife tried
to take him out oh [ __ ] but but who did
the actual shooting they just hired some
well each guy was different the Tupac
was shot by gangbangers and then a
biggie smalls was shot by rampart or
empire what's that the police department
mmm that's a big conspiracy that's why I
was Nauticus but why would the police
before but why would the police kill or
you mean it was that was it that group
forgot a part that got busted yeah
well if that would make sense the coast
battle there's so many people dying they
didn't they didn't want to get out of
control right no dude it's just like you
know there's a fine line my grandfather
was a cop and I don't think my mom
listens his podcast
even though she's big fans um she my
grandfather was a cop he was a very high
up and to say they grew up in and when
he died I went to his memorial and my
father basically showed me this side of
the room was the but was the police
department this side of the room was the
Mafia and that's how it [ __ ] went
there is a fine line between law and
order and cry it's like which side do
you want to plant and sometimes those
things blend dude and when you're
running and gunning you know hanging and
banging dog you know sometimes you end
up working with the people that your
souls would go now one of affairs what
exactly was the rampart thing so so my
old girlfriend dated one of those guys
for a while who is doing and so the
rampart division was a gang it was a
division a crack sort of division that
was supposed to deal with gangs
surprise right crackdown on gangs and
they said that they ended up becoming
their own gang of course because these
guys were these guys take the money in
the drug to start price Mavericks you
know they were kind of like badass kind
of was movie plot of all time well well
you know and like I'm training football
right Oh Ohio State you make a good play
you're gonna get an eye on your face
sure these guys would walk around with
those equivalents of like taking out
gang members and stuff like that and
eventually once you start like that
dealing with the gangs deal with it like
I realize that there's a lot of trucks
out there how money you can make a
little money more money on the side so
what happened the whole thing comes down
is when they arrest this guy this cop
was trying to take out another cop or
slug lines or those guys that bring up
the rampart case so the cop they're
trying to take out these cops right or
they catch this one cop doing something
bad and they they arrest them in their
interrogate him they're both interrogate
me opens up with his osis about the bank
robberies and that's when it all Hut
yeah yeah oh man it all starts to
unravel and they start realizing these
two dudes man
dude if you got that mustache I soon
okay I agree that's my rule I agree me
we're those mustaches you're up to no
[ __ ] neither those mustaches or if
you drive a van rampart scandal
widespread police corruption in the
community resources against street
hoodlums crash anti-gang unit in the
late 1990s more than 70 police officers
will are assigned or associated with a
rampart crash unit and they were
implicated in some form misconduct
making it one of the most widespread
cases of documented police corruption in
the United States history responsible
for a long list of offenses including
unprovoked shootings unprovoked beatings
remaining of false evidence stealing and
dealing narcotics H in bank robbery
perjury and covering up evidence of
these activities were done click on the
ties to death row records we're trying
to solve a goddamn case it's pretty
badass man huh
ties to the Bloods corner Frank lega who
shot him Kevin Gaines is flashing gang
signs and waving a gun ties to the
murder victorious b.i.g this Wikipedia
so it's official bro April 16 2007
George Wallace that's biggie filed
wrongful death suit E and city of Los
Angeles which also named the defendants
rampart officers yeah B of them Wow
so they did catch they were present the
night of the murder
inaudible MERS iam what's up they did
catch Biggie's murderer well they they
basically came out yeah and this is
frankly yeah ma they actually know the
guy who did it he went to jail it's like
all this crazy [ __ ] he was a he was a
cop yeah you can see it it did write
this out the city of Los Angeles faced
more than 140 civil suits resulting from
the rampart scandal paid a total
estimated settlement cost of 125 milk
here's my whole theory on everything doc
when it comes to money and power
anything's possible and people will do
anything to keep it and get it and you
can't expect like we we put a big thing
in this country is we like to project
our views our beliefs on how we see the
world on the people we don't know right
that's right we think it description
like whatever politician you want
whatever you
I don't believe in groups I'm straight
up Ronin dog I like I wandered the [ __ ]
you know Ronin you know ironic that's an
expression go rogue nope Ronin is an
expression for the for the samurai
so during feudal Japan there were show
guns and the Shogun's had their own
samurai and the samurai were there sort
of like legion of mercenaries and they
would they were always fighting for
territory so Japan really was under
really had a civil war low-grade civil
war for almost a thousand years and a
full-fledged one for about three hundred
years so if you ever wonder why that
tiny island almost took over all of
Ronin is a lone samurai Ronin is a
samurai who doesn't have an allegiance
to a Shogun and that's what you wanders
and he's kind of like I don't join the
gun for hire he's a lone gun for hire
that's pretty like ever since I started
this podcast will that be a group I
realized that it's [ __ ] people join
groups and they fight for groups and
they they fight for people they don't
even know and they've never met and they
weren't even there when the decisions
were made and they end up defending
actions they have no saying or agree
with just because he's on your team well
that that's the problem with joining a
team is that you forget about the
problem in the middle so what happens is
you go now they're the team leaders got
he's doing the thinking I got the bullet
points what I do know is I'm gonna be a
soldier and attack the other two huh but
you forget about what the [ __ ] of the
price way easier to be against something
that and then to define what you're Sam
you have any conspiracies on the Charles
Manson murders there's this whole theory
that uh you know you know we just had
armed uh what's-his-name leary leary
leary Zack Leary who was Timothy Leary
son who was helped basically create like
LSD and Jesus the whole theory is that
the government used the the Grateful
Dead to spread hippie culture and acid
so wherever the Grateful Dead went
suddenly acid was everywhere they were
well they were into it and their
followers but but it's like if you fall
Joe Rogan you probably gonna be into we
search her but but but but to do Idol a
guy who worked with them directly
created like it was like he created the
acid that was spreading like it wasn't
just like people came to them and had
acid I think people they were worried I
don't know that Timothy Leary's they got
created acid but I think Timothy Leary
is certainly a visual proponent of
psychedelics right I mean like he's
working with this group called maps
what's the prize - uh Manson well Manson
if there's a belief that there and we're
going deep in I love us men but he was
they used they use those murders to
vilify the hippie culture so that yeah
well I get the the media spin they put
on like yeah and family and all that the
a lot of that was kind of you know it
was good for a story the narrative was
well they use it to basically demonize
hippies like do you can't trust these
hippies that makes it's all interesting
stuff dude
but everything's everything is a story
you got a cell so they're gonna package
it like crazy man and family they're on
LSD and acid which they were non-stop
right operation Mockingbird
there is a just move to basically plant
assets in throughout the media to be
able to spin stories the way they want
to
now if Eddie Bravo's attend in this what
are you a nine see here's the whole
thing about that it's just like Eddie
Bravo is Eddie Bravo and like I don't
believe in I I'm open to the idea of
simulation theory than anything but what
I say with Eddie Bravo is this is like I
may not believe in what he's saying but
something's going on that's all I'm
saying if we're there smoke except
there's a flatter assessment planners go
no there's no I'm not saying there's a
flat earth I'm saying something's going
on that these people who if you took
that away that one part of Eddie away
that one thing right there's the Flat
Earth thing you did it away didn't exist
and you looked at Eddie you'd be like
he's a little Crazy's little this but
he's accomplished a lot he's a hard
worker he's a nice dude yeah
trust them like I don't think he'd lie
to me if we were in a fight I think he'd
man up and have my back like a this book
so everything else lines up except for
this one crazy-ass [ __ ] thing now the
only thing with Eddie is I think that
any identifying is wrongly as somebody
who's the leader of conspiracy movement
so when you identify very strongly with
a particular team there's one thing but
also I think that the problem with the
conspiracy belief in widespread
conspiracies is that you are assuming
that people in power ie the government
or whoever it might be or the government
within the government are all of the
same mind and all agree as we know and
as we yeah and that out to get you well
as we all know nobody you can do you at
the unit the United States government
can never keep a secret because like us
all kinds of people have different
points of view okay let's say it out
like Snowden and different agendas and
exactly and different agendas so even
when even when the NSA has this large
operation to try to listen in on all
your stuff and collect like Brad on one
team
no it's it's a the history would would
prove me wrong I would like to tell I
would like to comment on that and go
okay so here's what's going on dude okay
what what really happens with
conspiracies and is that there are
people who uh have time on their hands
and I'll be it like I'm a comedian I I
bust my ass getting these gigs I do this
but I'm some time on my hands I'm not a
nine-to-five guy I don't have a family I
don't have all these things that consume
my time so I have time to go out and
read it and read all this [ __ ] and use
my brain a common sense of my 45 years
on this planet which I've honed this
[ __ ] meter to a very high level
through stand-up comedy so I know
[ __ ] I don't know yeah it's like why
people always try to [ __ ] like I tell
people like you're trying to pull [ __ ]
over on comics like we are the most
[ __ ] sensitive to everything
paranoid [ __ ] on the plan we've
been [ __ ] we've had trains run on us
for [ __ ] so long that we know when
bullshit's coming so when you pull
something we see it happening so you're
like trying to pull Jedi tricks on
Jedi's it doesn't [ __ ] work
okay so I'm [ __ ] I get a [ __ ]
meter like a [ __ ] but what I
find is that when I argue with people or
debate like we are doing right now and
this is nothing against anybody but I'm
debating with people that haven't done
the research that haven't really dove
into it and taking a look at it because
they don't have time to they'll assume
they both because it's like again it's
like we're projecting onto people so we
see here we go oh that's never happened
before because we don't have time to
look into it so what we do is we go to
people that we trust because for the
longest time we should have trust them
okay the media we trusted them in in in
the in the mid 90s the Clint's came in
and they deregulate the media what they
did well it started with Reagan where he
got rid of where you were supposed to
every newscast had to have the point and
the counterpoint
well Reagan got rid of that you didn't
know that's not true you see the problem
Sam is that you're really simplifying
major major developments in in
collective points of view and no one and
the government especially didn't force a
news agency to have a point or a counter
point okay and Ronald Reagan Ronald
Reagan didn't have the jitters one man
wrote Sam to to dictate to the media how
to run their news that's just not
factual
it's just isn't known as another dude
there was a law that stated you had to
have both the point and the counterpoint
to it Reagan made that he got rid of
that that you didn't have to have a
counterpoint on your show and then what
happened was Clinton there came in and
deregulated the media meaning that there
used to be a rule that you would could
only own like one media outlet in a
market you could know multiple yeah I
can I just can I just can I just let me
just try to piggyback on that for a
second to give it a little more clarity
a little bit big one bitter bad I issued
the biggest issue is not that in the
First Amendment the First Amendment
allows you to broadcast whatever it is
you want well the First Amendment has
always allowed us to broadcast what you
want so as a news organization the
there's no question that one would
always try to be objective with the
journalism okay right agendas right yeah
and there are some great of course and
there are some great journalists who
were always very good about being as
objective as possible however yes the
New York Times was liberal for the most
part yes the Wall Street Journal was
primarily conservative yes the
economists one of the oldest magazines
in the world was rather conservative but
for the most part the idea was always to
be objective but the biggest issue was
when 60 minutes I believe it was there's
a famous story about when they got
really high ratings and the
editor-in-chief came in and said I have
good news and bad news good news is we
just crushed in the ratings the bad news
is we just crushed in the ratings in
other words we just crossed the line
from news to entertainment and when you
as a news organization like Fox News or
whatever are you listening yes I am
whenever the when when when now you're
sort of livelihood depends on your
ratings and selling news now you're
compromised so now the media's where now
the media is about clickbait now the
media is about now so now now that's why
the media for Americans I think the
media's approval rating and I love it is
in the single digits because you're
right I believe most journalism today is
very irresponsible right I think it's
very hard to believe in anything because
there it is and in every debate and it's
click ok ok so you agree that that news
before this the news before in in the
1670s was probably to an extent
something you could rely on more because
it was more objective okay 1987 yeah
okay ah the it's called the Fairness
Doctrine okay Reagan eliminates Reagan
allows the FCC to eliminate the Fairness
dr-drop doctrine which required that
they made every reasonable attempt to
cover contrasting points of view right
okay that's gone that is basically what
I was talking about then you had to have
an opposing view to counter what was
going on then in 1996 President Clinton
signs the telecommute telecommunication
Act of 1996 which basically allowed
which took away the cap on owning media
people so
the media outlets so before that you had
you could only own like so many mark
medium apple eyes in a thing now it went
from like think in nineteen in 1989 or
some number like that there were eighty
companies owned ninety percent of the
media in this country now it's down to
six six country six companies own all
the media ok enough so everyone has
their agenda I feel yeah and it's like
and here's my whole thing man like if we
look at you guys are killing it on this
podcast man and it's like because this
is new media man you guys are your own
guys your Ronan's right of media so but
if you look at what's going on with
network news network television all that
stuff dude nobody's watching it and
you're like well why isn't anybody
watching it well because the people who
own these channels man they make the
real money and what I call God gold oil
and drugs all right
banking oil and pharmaceuticals that's
where the real money is why what
television is millions of billions we're
talking trillions these are trillions of
dollars and these things are they they
control the media and they don't care
what the numbers are because it's more
about them getting across an agenda
here's my corporate interests I'm
talking about the six companies yeah
that oh that's right the media and then
those thirds I love them own those six
companies so it's like conflict of
interest Viacom for sure and all those
huge crime TV look at MTV dude nobody
watch it like like we're around the same
age yeah MTV was the [ __ ] it was the
counterculture the MTV Music Awards was
an event everybody hang out we're gonna
watch what's Madonna gonna do what's my
ring break everything was it was like it
was huge it was it moved the needle dude
now nobody watches it
well they watch t mom though that's
their big one that's their book what is
that number when you say that's their
big one well what is anyone's number two
every everything as far as TV is down oh
I disagree there are actually shows
sports are little bit but there are
actually shows that on today's like gets
like ah 12 million couple Shane MacGowan
Thrones but there was no believe it or
big
call or live sports what was the show
with the duck calling guys those guys
got over 13 million dollars and 13
million followers
yeah there are shows that do it but but
your point is there's multimedia but
everything's down because the content no
but you're saying you're saying that the
number I know exactly what you're saying
the problem with trying to get objective
news is that these news organizations
are owned by corporations that have
their own agenda was the tight MTV
though but the MTV okay here's all so
Prince dies right Prince dies it's a
major moment in this because he was
culturally this humongous dude dies MTV
starts playing all these videos their
numbers skyrocket and they're like whoa
whoa whoa
our numbers just exploded from playing
these music videos maybe we should play
music videos that idea lasted for two
weeks and then went back to will tell
you life and times of being a gay porn
star would you like more life but right
but they did launch TRL now try and
bring back the old well let's see the
work and I'm totally down so much of
that is literally like anything else
somebody comes to the brass with an idea
they want right now it's impossible it
always goes back to what are what are we
going to be able to sell see now the
news has become the Fairness Doctrine
and and all of that stuff which really
fell under the idea which was challenged
by you know the the Reagan
administration the Clinton is raised
really under the first the First
Amendment was the notion that you can't
force anybody to you know impose an
agenda right so a counterpoint or that
the biggest issue became when there was
money to be made in the news where your
ratings mattered where Fox News came up
and said we're the conservative group
you guys the liberal media is really
liberal and people [ __ ] went to it in
droves you can sell advertising space
right that's what compromises it goes
back to money and power it goes back to
[ __ ] who owns I'm saying what I said
earlier which is can I ask you guys
something
yeah it's the biggest sodium biggest
story in in politics right now would it
be Michael Floyd stuff that's non-stop
have you guys heard the Awan brothers
Jonah Irwin I fabric count I'm talking
about the Awan brother
no yes that story is [ __ ] huge
and nobody's talking about it fill us in
its these IT guys from Pakistan who
worked for 80 different people in
Congress and sat in the Senate and
basically it was found out that they
were their IT security guys and they
were they had all their passwords to all
their emails and they were selling all
these secrets to Pakistan yeah and
nobody's talking about that then that's
all fat that's not yeah I'm sure it is
I'm sure it's true do you want brothers
put me why it's crazy and now do you
want come on the show to get super
silent is great fun I think it's
important [ __ ] I talk a lot say what's
fascinating those like with MTV the
problem they're having a lot of these
networks are having with the Millennials
they don't have the attention span
anymore yeah so like hour-long specials
Netflix doing 30 minute specials now for
comedy a lot of these shows they do in
five minutes I'd like to get one five
minutes five ten a year well okay well
you have ten a year no but with you with
MTV they're saying that a wonda shows
aren't working why W ans yeah I believe
it's aw yeah Ilan's yeah there it is
debbie Wasserman Schultz Pakistani guys
Reza Airport yeah dude
she is just evil to who she looks like a
haunted [ __ ] pumpkin ah but yeah it's
big so that's what we like why is it
sorted because everything's agenda and
everything that's what it is like
endless Ahmet because you're selling
entertainment and no longer than news I
mean I'm telling Trump's entertainment I
mean it's you can sell when you just
float a rumor they were talking about
Chris Rock who was trying to work out a
[ __ ] [ __ ] Chris Rock yes and he's
trying to work out a bit at the Comedy
Cellar dude the Comedy Cellar is where
someone like Chris Rock works out his
[ __ ] before he takes it worldwide which
means you're gonna say [ __ ] that might
be controversial that might be you know
it's not fully developed so he's
thinking on stage and Chris the kind of
comically writes on stage if you ever
watch yeah and so he said some [ __ ] that
was you know offensive to somebody
because it had to do with sort of sexual
assault but he's trying to figure it out
snot
fear though cuz you're exactly it's not
fair and the woman who saw it called The
Washington Post now watch this the
Washington Post runs the bullet points
of what they heard okay or something
like that so so it was like basically
Chris Rock says controversies happen but
and they have this was I saw that you
told me about this so all of a sudden so
all of no no that's not the point
that wasn't the point Chris Rock is fine
right you have to realize that when the
post does that and it says Chris walk
and then you have some thing on it you
can just attach the shoulders ah you get
Chris Rock you can have controversial
controversial statement on sexual
assault that's all you have to say what
you have to realize is that okay nobody
can sell that they can sell that that
that score it also makes it yes right
hundred different outlets they did a
thing where it was like it was sold to
like like 100 200 300 outlets worldwide
all those views are money first yes
their money for some of all that right
well like with Dave Chappelle and I said
at the belly room he closed it out and
he was the same thing he's up there just
feeling stuff out he's doing the sexual
assault stuff and he goes through it and
someone's filming us dude I'm gonna stop
because I swear to god I'm gonna stop if
you don't put your phone away
right he was Tracy Morgan was telling me
the other day saw this set and he goes
dude you would be banned from all sorts
of you get so much [ __ ] if this got out
he goes I'm just working I'm working on
it is I don't need you to blast this out
yeah man as I'm trying to figure out
what's gonna hit what's not that's why
I'm doing here you just put your phone
away I'm gonna stop doing my show and
stand-up comedy is that I hate when
people record me like that it drives me
[ __ ] with that show right there I go
what are you doing dog yeah put the
[ __ ] phone down
so disrespectful man it's so
disrespectful drives me crazy but you
know what else I don't like and
sometimes you do this beat but this is
what makes you great like will do bits
about you know we joke around being gay
and Brian goes now we're not trying to
offend anyone I don't think at the comic
store or anyplace coming you should have
to apologize before you do it right I
don't think there's any comedy as soon
as the door everyone's on the same lever
we're all good you might see some
offensive [ __ ] you're there for them
we're not there there's nothing it's you
know here's my like the Lucy
stuff dude you know and it's like in
retro and and I feel for them and I
respect their whole thing the whole part
after I think the real stuff comes with
the pressure to shut up pressuring these
girls who shut up and the management
coming in and [ __ ] really pounding on
them but like in in the the spectrum of
like sexual assault what we're seeing
like Matt Lawler having a [ __ ] lock
it down button the not letting girls
leave like in a spectrum like Lucy Ches
like if I could have gotten this out
like a week in it like yeah yeah later
it'd be a whole different world for
mothers levels this sexual assault right
right right right right Weinstein be but
but here's the thing about Lucy K the
people that are grilling him right now
are the same people who let him get away
with everything grad but I feel actually
Joseph died down
I wouldn't Bobby Lee's podcast and I
taught I told the story about Paul
Mooney calling me the N word and how
Anna reason I tell its stories cuz Paul
Mooney Teresa I'm a regular at The
Comedy Store but he called me the n-word
right and I said the n-word on think and
some people went nuts on that right can
you say that we can't even say the word
in context of being called it right now
but these people allowed Lewis CK to say
the n-word allowed him to talk about all
the weird sexual shitty wanted to do
they lie and then they're the ones who
[ __ ] turned on them and it's just
like we have these [ __ ] [ __ ]
rules and I do this thing called
oppression math it's this bit I do about
how like the more you your group has
been oppressed the more the crowd will
let you get away with [ __ ] yeah and then
it all peaks at if you're a fat you're a
fat black gay [ __ ] you can [ __ ]
scorch the earth black gay woman [ __ ]
yeah you can say whatever the [ __ ] you
want dude and it's just the truth too
because I mean I'll follow somebody
dropping n bombs
black people go crazy and then I'll go
up and I'll just have a simple
conversation about something and man I
hear [ __ ] just click click click
click up tight nose funny as your
Armenian and Lebanese aren't you I'm
Armenian Italian okay so the Armenians
suffered of 1204 meaning comedian they
still suffered their own genocide so to
call you white or privilege is reduced
as somebody who doesn't understand it's
worse is when white chicks go on the
internet and call somebody white
privilege that is the most
I mean like what doing nope well that
doesn't help anybody either does it
white printing mean by white number one
different kinds of white I feel like
with louis c.k though it's died down a
tad for him yeah I think he's gonna be
all becomes more more monster [ __ ]
starts coming out you're like okay maybe
you know it's like if you had to be in a
room louis c.k may not be the worst one
of em he's like almost like starter kit
you know like training wheels of [ __ ]
sex what I think what's gonna come out
of all of it is that men are for the
first time gonna have to like realize
you can't just any ground but I also
think these these guys and I will call
them [ __ ] the heads of networks or
control the power who are turning on the
actual like they might be good guys they
made mistakes and they turn on them and
they're all you know trying to be all
the suspects me too and of these white
[ __ ] Knights I think the the real men
are gonna weather the storm and it's
gonna come back to fold and we'll see
what's I also think what you have that
people need to understand about
Hollywood is that we are artists to la
vez our artists but this is a business
and this is no different than trying to
get ahead and Washington DC or on
[ __ ] Wall Street and there is a
cutthroat you know you're so goddamn
[ __ ] and like the left the make it at
the highest levels there's almost a you
have to have a level of psychopath okay
and you have to like win at all costs
and I'm not saying they're bad people
but the amount of drive you have to have
correct but not only that no let's be
really honest I've been here for 23
years when I got here I said to my buddy
would tell me about LA my buddy was
working on a TV show and he said to me
this is in 1995 he said a lot of sex for
sale a lot of sex for sale and I said
what do you mean he goes you'll say and
what I'll say after 23 years is yeah
there is a chap in my ass
now it really has impale I built up a
serious handle cows but I'm sorry but no
and I mean I'm glad you said that
because because they're do you no doubt
there is no [ __ ] doubt that they
weren't there are a lot of smart people
men and women the probably more women
and talented men and women more more
women and I know some of them who have
[ __ ] very strategically in this
business
yes very strategically and got
themselves where they needs to they
weren't [ __ ] they weren't [ __ ] they
were just they were like you know what I
could [ __ ] Joe Johnny over here behind
that Bambi and I could be [ __ ] in
wonder I could [ __ ] mr. vice president
over here who's pretty cute but if
successful guy maybe not as hot as that
guy tell me this on him tell me this
because that watch is that any different
down let's and on I don't have a problem
with them is that any different than
some super hot girl going holy [ __ ] he's
the starting quarterback for the Denver
Broncos I'm gonna [ __ ] him I'm out of a
great life yes
I'm do I like him we'll figure it out
but what I do know is if I make a
connection with him I get this a to beat
me at something with her let me add
something else it's also I think it's
society it's your life
let me think they don't like them let me
let me ask something else but also let
me add so it's all suppressed we blow
comes out both parties usually and I'm
not talking about I'm not talking about
a boss who's the scumbag who takes
advantage of a vulnerable young woman
who wants to get a job and then pulls
some [ __ ] on it that's not what I'm
talking about because you're an [ __ ]
if you do that that is sexual harassment
what I'm talking about is in this
business of Hollywood there is both
sides benefit in this equation most of
the time I've seen it over and over so
yes yes there are a lot of powerful men
that have sex with youngers more power
women though in Hollywood so here's what
I'm pointing is my point we also know
the power I cheer cat without hitting a
hot chick well now is but there's more
powerful men yes making the decisions
there are we
there are yes there are well hold on let
me tell you just directors know a
hundred percent but listen to this what
I'm saying is this and you're 100% right
that women are also attracted to power
and powerful Mel folate a lot yeah even
in this I decide when I used to work at
a strip I've seen the chicks with Oliver
those are all the time yes I've seen
this over and over again so it's a
complicated dynamic if we don't get a
dining options it's gone
so dude I totally agree that we manage
those Sam well I don't what do they get
up for [ __ ] yeah so yeah it's a better
ship gets hey my girlfriend was a
stripper and she used this is terrible
to say but she used to bang her herd the
owner of the club I'll see you because
he now yeah well you know she said no
don't
what [ __ ] me no the super light she
loved me did you and you thought her and
he's not a real name with cinnamon okay
Karen that's not a real name was
cinnamon cakes about a god-given name
yeah there are people name their kids
dripper names yeah so anyway cinnamon
cakes if you don't mind can you wipe the
[ __ ] cynical look on your face
cinnamon can she walk in the manager for
what for [ __ ] better cultivation
couple things yeah she got the best
ships
she got do you get away with on times
sometimes he'd give it away wouldn't
that be like she didn't want it hard I
mean listen man strip bars it's a dying
if you had a bigger dick
maybe he's better look at ya maybe you
cheated on me however you when you work
there I just graduated college it was a
gift to myself I'm like I worked hard I
went to [ __ ] College I'm gonna work at a
strip bar and white guards LV dogging
UNLV football doc I live objection that
run of it I used to do stand-up
I had my eye I basically Doug Stanhope
started the Vegas comedy scene but I'm
the one who basically created the the
base for it when I started doing stamp
in Vegas there was one open mic every
other week so I was like [ __ ] this dude
I gotta get stage time everywhere and so
what I started doing was just I go to
bars a head stage I go what's your
emptied what's your slow night they're
like twos
give me a show of it packed and this was
before myspace or the internet I would
pack out every night somewhere and I
would host it but I'd be like a black
host in an urban night you know where
I've never seen anybody anybody I've
never seen you have a bad set and I've
never seen you ever not destroy in front
of any crowd you can [ __ ] it we were
sorry knife dog we were in Afghan own
teams do by the way you guys play home
games alt and God bless you and I'm so I
love watching everything you guys are
doing is on fire the kid crowds are
let's talk about any crime II like you
guys show hey Bryan Callen British I'm
gonna be here boom they show up me dude
it's like I have no clue what's going on
in that room and I gotta go in there and
just like that's what you're so good
swing that's why you should kick in to
home teams though it's you're the funny
Atari when we meet dub David of Steve
Byrne and Sam went to Afghanistan ten
days and we had to go and with like I'm
telling you 3:00 in the afternoon
would like some shitty mic and a bunch
of so-so jurors he would be the he would
be the Icebreaker he'd be the Icebreaker
cuz I was like I don't want to go out
right now oh we got I got it you
couldn't open because you're just a
you're just a [ __ ] guy you can't open
up when I don't know hooking the Bruce
Springsteen of stand-up comedy Bruce
Springsteen music video watch that and
tell me him and Bryan Callen aren't
[ __ ] the same kind of entertain a
challenge Brian listen so he can't go up
and his Steve Burns tour and like dub
never opened offered to open up the
shell never once and that you got you
[ __ ] killed my morning my favorite
Sam Tripoli jokes is I got to keep doing
this so karate starts paying the bills
but anyway we're never I've been popping
I'm like I [ __ ] hate this guy yeah
you guys something out yeah I know you
know I didn't join this right now but
I'm only doing this until Chrysler's pay
the bill so [ __ ] you guys dog kills me
that's one joke of 50,000 she's gonna
throw those out the time I mean I
started coming man I started putting out
the bill yeah I know else I started Tom
Segura I know I was in a [ __ ] euro
cheaper Groundlings class when I'm like
there
this moment dude like I'm a competitive
[ __ ] when it comes to comedy and
like you could either have that moment
you're like ah dude we got another
gunslinger here or you can be like I
like this guy won't be friends with him
right and Tom cigar was so [ __ ] fast
I'm like I get either [ __ ] be like a
[ __ ] rival or I could be like love
this guy so I'm like dude you why you're
successful you can stand up yeah he goes
I never try to go come with me I'll show
you how to do it and for a week I took
that dude around for [ __ ] showing you
how long there was this amazing Sam like
I wanted 11 years ago I guess in the
world he's amazed you remember when I
used to call you the monsters you know
why'd remember what when I started doing
that well I would always have to [ __ ]
follow you right I did an hour of I
[ __ ] and at The Comedy Store in La
Jolla
I threw flames I [ __ ] literally got
off the stage and I went there's no way
anybody on the planet I was being
serious and rides on Brian's not Brian
day everybody this is my show night I
don't know if he gets mammy by Mike Mike
this last show was like the greatest
murderer I've ever put together it was
such a fun show and I'm like there's
only one dude that could close that out
who does take care and it's like him
he's like I gotta get up I gotta get to
this other [ __ ] place I'm like okay
just go up do like do like 10 15 and get
out 40 minutes later he's like and then
why he's blocking it people are loving
them and it's just like I hope you make
your spot but do you're the only one
that could close it you're the only one
I love doing it but I thought the comic
store I through flames and I was just
like I never forgot I did it a full hour
and five minutes and I go there's just
Sam's gotta follow me I love him and I
know you're tough but I go there's no
one who can follow that know it was just
because sometimes in a room when you
take that much oxygen out of a room
they're all gone this [ __ ] guy gets
up not even missing a beat and I'm not
I've counted the minutes I'll never
forget it because I couldn't stop
watching for 55 minutes
he had them laughing he had them
laughing as hard or harder you just you
just destroyed I was like bin sessional
Oh
professional profound and when there's
listen man obviously without the comstor
I get great advice but there's a few
guys where if they say something you
Sam Rogan if you say some I'm [ __ ] on
yes much experience not to listen you
know what your thing is is uh Brian is
hand and I'm not just saying cuz here
its hands down when they brought you a
lot it makes yes is hurting as well but
he's one of the best comedians in the
world but I feel like is I feel like if
you if you don't seem in person it it
doesn't come it doesn't train like yeah
we need to figure out how to shoot a
special where people feel that energy
cuz your whole thing is energy but on
video it's not don't get me wrong
people like that's information so my
figure though he's blown up I feel like
Sebastian in the room yeah Bret Ernst is
very much like that yeah Bret Ernst you
sure guide you you see my TV go there
good you seen a personal well he's
[ __ ] brilliant
this next special I have to figure it
out yeah cuz it's a game-changer
yeah well I mean like I've always said
you're the most unique dude like I've
watched you've cultivate this mmm
I help them get in at the Comedy Store
yeah he did you I remember go you're not
a man right good yeah I was like oh dude
you don't even know I got so many people
into Comedy Store cuz I figured out the
[ __ ] the formula on how to get him in
and so I'm like we need to [ __ ] it cuz
it was when I got picked up the
connoisseur it was dad dude I would walk
in this how long ago was Steve
Rannazzisi was working the door and I
would walk in speak owes he we'd look at
the or he goes should I be looking for a
new job I go I don't know dog man since
I've been here yeah we would go up and
it was like 20 people member that dude
back in the day notice how many stores
like you also also there were there
rooms there were secret reviews oh it
was your best
I missed the outlaw days outlaw days be
outlaw there's a lot of guys who worked
the door like Ari Shaffir Steve
Rannazzisi Bobby Lee uh who else a meta
man that hey soos now Trejo's a monster
he he's a great one he used to be like
you did that before you became a writer
then there were some people but I
learned the code so I'd be like we got
we got a buff bang this [ __ ] line
about so it had to work Tommy I didn't
the [ __ ] and be like give this guy
[ __ ]
showcase and what I would do is when the
showcase came I would sit next to Mitzi
and I would [ __ ] block anybody from
talking I remember that remember to
focus on it he and I met and that did
that i sat there and I'm like Mitzi
killer killer killer and I got you in I
got Steve burn in God if you guys got
dove in
I got L magical in I got Ian Edwards
it's Jon REEP in Jesus yeah I got
everybody in because I was just like
dude you're good
we need the buff and I would sit there
but the problem was I got bumped all the
way to the end of the [ __ ] line up
because the lineup was such a killer
which kind of made me the comic I am
today because I would just have to get
like fighting uphill I'd have like a
necrophiliac on the original remember
the original room I've performed all
over the [ __ ] country all over the
all over the you know Canada there's no
doubt in my opinion if you can crush in
the original room you can crush anywhere
it's like the equivalent of lifting
heavy what's my goal man I got to do a
sin oh this [ __ ] right here I'm
like dude what you are trying to do is
trying to learn the what you're doing is
equivalent and you could do whatever you
want you've earned everything you got
and I would never tell you anything
you've learned everything i love
watching doing what you're doing you are
trying to learn it's basically MMA
you're trying to learn MMA in the
Octagon yeah I ain't [ __ ] rooms and
they burned it dude every [ __ ] guy
but he would do himself well to do some
open mic I got this new room that I keep
telling dude it's the most [ __ ]
proper room cuz the store is dude that
is the pinnacle yeah you everybody I
talked to I don't care who the fisa for
would you don't get right in the Octagon
right away right his first stand-up 1200
screaming people in Seattle yeah I got
you dude he's [ __ ] got balls I could
never I just stood off the phone with
Joey Diaz who is arguably the hardest
human being to follow when he is on
correct I mean dude I had to follow him
following J open I used to feature for
Joe Rogan man I had to follow [ __ ]
Joey Diaz at a Joe Rogan show which is
like middling for Van Halen but the
opening act
it's David Lee Roth okay like you're
walking into I'm a commercial break I'm
a [ __ ] smoke break and I was just I'm
not a smoker i fouled to him and Lisa
Lampanelli one time oh my gosh have you
ever seen Lisa Lampanelli life yes oh I
threw his like freely as I do well with
no [ __ ] bottom you're just like bro
throw your punch like is it nothing well
I mean come on you're following like I
had to follow Lisa Lampanelli one time
in New York City and I never worry about
following anyway I don't care I followed
everybody from Chris Rock to you know
you name it and Lisa Lampanelli took all
the oxygen out of the room it's only
funny she did really racist stuff it's
only she's like oh you're sitting next
to the Puerto Rican guy watch your purse
ma'am then what the funny because it's
true she was just like they're 101 and
and I mean forget it you try following
that up and I was like hey what's the
deal with penguins the [ __ ] out yeah get
done for hey you get the [ __ ] out of
here hey hey you skinny white guy you
suck average right thank you [ __ ] you
you know the movie abs are you a lunge
talking about a sword get the [ __ ] outta
just a bowl [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
thing New York City is I get Darfur what
bring the racist back up yeah yeah
so Joey Diaz I get fun with him today
cuz he's gonna come on my podcast talk
about Bruce Lee's death right but he's
like dude dog I got I got to find some
work on [ __ ] that all and then have a
comedy so you got to [ __ ] him fire every
night and that's the funniest dude I
know yeah like you and have the funniest
dudes I know talking about how you can't
just walk up Joey and I had that
conversation I talked to him pray a week
ago he's a dog the Comedy Store
dude you got a you can't you can't try
[ __ ] you got it you got a go somewhere
you gotta figure it out the 3-stone you
gotta work it dude it's all murderers
just like he goes it's not like it is
back in the day goes you you can't go
there and do new [ __ ] because you gotta
come you've been put in the lineup
arguably with the best comics in the
country yeah over and over
yeah you know only a fighter like him
only a [ __ ]
dude who's faced Giants in the Octagon
wouldn't [ __ ] their pants every time
right I'm get somebody just done so much
you know you the beauty is that you have
the attitude to follow and that is half
of it right most comics when they start
to get over the stage fry and all that
stuff don't think I would say he's also
got a sense of humor he's also yeah I
mean he's good hot cast wouldn't be huge
yeah you can also say he's gonna you
were great and you were dead weight it
wouldn't [ __ ] work it's like you guys
meet each other I care you guys touch
dicks Chinese hand you say this is the
Chinese hang low blow up blow air into
his wings yeah yeah it looks like in New
York City comedy club bouncer I go there
and work on new [ __ ] whereas I'm in it's
called the sycamore Tavern and I'm
trying to give in something called the
club upstairs the dojo right I love that
want them place to go work on you and
when dude I love closing the doors and
having comics who've been do comedy
forever open the door and be like oh
[ __ ] this is for real I'll do it it
looks like in New York City so if you're
working on an hour you know somewhere to
do an hour it's hard to get like The
Improv the comics or everything this
room I'm setting it up so people can go
in there work on a [ __ ] hour the
Friday night the Monday night show is
called FOMO fear of missing out cuz I
buy you out on the Monday right but it's
gonna be like an open mic for
established comedians we're like guys
who like on a certain level can bring
quality and work on their new [ __ ] and
not the word and you can't go up there
doing [ __ ] all right genius I just I
love comedy dude I love comedians I love
comedy you know The Comedy Store is just
this [ __ ] the mecca dude and you
can't [ __ ] around there no so you got to
have somewhere to work it out cuz this
is the only thing you could do in you
have to like it's the only art dude that
you have to do in front of people and
that's almost why comedians get put over
the barrel because they need that stage
time yeah and the people who own the
stage know that knowing you're gonna do
it how many times a week sin well these
Mondays every Monday every Monday
there's a FOMO show and then we're
starting to try to book the right people
to get they want to go every night and
it's just like it's this little
where you could just go and work on [ __ ]
and that's why I'm trying to create a
place where people can work out [ __ ]
because hundred-seven it's just like
there's I'm a killers now there's too
many killers under percent it's who
knows in the audience at the Comedy
Store come to the dojo and [ __ ] work
it I love that side the dojo I'm trying
to convince them dude I got there and I
spent a lot of time and go jazz through
my life you know I'm a martial art I've
that's wrong I'm gonna take a piss
really take a hard piss is that the news
get out of here well when he started
talking about dojo no I literally got it
Sarju Jitsu bird save their already
bladder well I'm on that dodging ah [ __ ]
it drinks water and eats fat and protein
and he caught a bug his collar all the
way up dude I had to I had to do
whatever you want I had sweet potato
fries yesterday and they had cinnamon on
them they were so good and I go I didn't
know you cheated like that yeah I eat I
eat good carbs I go ahead and get
involved in these he goes can't I go
it's one fry I can't I was like hey eat
a [ __ ] fry I can't that's why you
guys are successful I can't I just like
don't give a [ __ ] no I don't believe in
discipline Sam I don't believe in
discipline I believe in I believe that
be the reason that I eat the way I do is
I feel better the reason I work out is
if I feel better there's nothing to do
it this one it's pleasurable to me the
idea that you know everybody out there's
like I gotta get discipline I got so
whenever you say I got to start eating
better watch
I gotta start working out that sounds
punishing [ __ ] I hate it
I love come hang with me and watch how I
do it it or you just start getting into
your body you start feeling different
and better when you eat this way versus
this way that's all it is so when I wake
up after drinking a lot of wine and
being an [ __ ] I'm like God my head's
all full and swollen and then when I
start eating clean and I'm working out I
feel energized and I would rather that
because I'm moving toward pleasure and
away from pain and if you can associate
good habits with pleasure that's how you
debts I get it instead of this [ __ ]
about the minute you start trying to
self restrict I don't believe in it it
doesn't last none of us can do it
none of us but then you get shamed then
you're told you don't have discipline
then you're told that you don't have
character then
you're told that you are weak and I
think that's ridiculous because all of
us have no discipline all of us are weak
and all of us can be shamed in one way
or another because we don't want to do
certain things I if you told me to sit
at a cubicle and work hard you told me I
have to the goal is to make money I
would be a disaster
that's not what motivates me never has
it's got to be something else I love it
to find out what motivates you find out
how to inspire yourself and then the
rest is [ __ ] cake no I get that man I
think it's about finding something you
enjoy doing women are better at picking
working out I mean did I just hear I
don't believe in discipline I don't who
said that I believe whole heart I know
you believe in inspiration everyone I
know - yes whatever gets you there dude
you don't believe in it you believe it
but no no you find that what I'm saying
is I believe in being inspired and
pleasure figure out a way to make
discipline pleasurable figure out a way
to make discipline inspire is not why
are you discipline right if you just
follow everything that you think is
gonna be good for you you want your your
brain is good that's good you're going
down that you're never gonna make it you
know I can be able to compete no no
that's not what I'm talking about so
when when so for example they always
talk about the most dangerous soldier in
the world why are the Israelis such
badasses because there is you have a
photo not why the Israelis have such
badasses because they have an ideology
because they're fighting for their
survival because they have a very strong
why so yes they can freeze them so yes
they can they can they can you know
freezing during endure tremendous
hardship you can endure tremendous
hardship when you very very crystal
clear on the why why are you doing this
what are you working towards and I think
some guys are you doing tougher and so
it's not gay I don't [ __ ] sir am is that
discipline right this is discipline how
he comes he never doesn't have some
dicks
he never doesn't have fluid comments
like Will Sasso he's like that he's like
the harder Will Sasso the 10-minute pod
still going it is that's great
yeah no selling it no no I don't own it
anymore I gave us will no will it's will
and his buddies doing it yeah oh it's
willness buddies doing oh it's cry it
was such a brilliant idea that was wills
idea it's a brilliant idea
he's like a TD Theatre you D'Elia last
night came up at there
the kid he's so [ __ ] funny so funny
such a good dude a nice guy best and
killing it treats people well you know
has every reason like it's I I get
amazed when people become [ __ ] when
they get famous and sometimes sometimes
no many I know some yeah when my friends
become famous
I get very I'm excited for them but
sometimes I get very I do get sad
because sometimes I think I'm not gonna
see this guy like I used to
I'm not gonna talk to him like I used to
you're gonna change I mean it happens I
think I don't I don't judge anybody dude
you know you know the one perk you guys
haven't changed Maz Jobrani is the same
[ __ ]
those Russell Peters and my peoples
Kevin Hart same guy Kevin Hart the
nicest [ __ ] dude and it happens but
sometimes you lose people
krisily has been a [ __ ] gem since the
moment I met that guy he's so open for
him I know me too
you know and I'm just like look at this
[ __ ] yesterday just looked at me
he looked at me and he likes to like
just torture man and there were these
beautiful girls behind us and I go looks
I just notice my goatees there the
beautiful girls and what were they when
they come from you know as a man you
like wow and he goes he goes hey man I
mean look who they're standing next to
yeah and he had an apologetic look I go
I go hey don't get me pissed off because
they were just there but he was taking
credit for it and he goes bro I'm sad in
my face and he goes leaves if I posted
the combos me and Chris have about
fashion people think we're just I left
the country
what is the frozen yellow Yeezys I sent
them to him I'm obsessed with and I said
to my your brine need these then a day
later he goes he brings out girls got
him so then I got him and then he warm
yesterday the comi store and I go has
Rogan seen those and he goes yes he
makes fun but I secretly think he likes
them and I agree with him they're the
worst I'm like dude and Jamie his
producer I'm like do we need get Rogen
some jeez he hates up I think he's
secretly I think they're so ugly
especially
yellow yellow the yellow easy they make
me laugh dude he makes me like so this
is like he is such a force of nature
Chris D'Elia my deniable when I watch
him do stand-up and what he does is he
back in the day I don't know if he still
does it but back in the day he would go
out you basically got a [ __ ]
highlighter for a sneaker is that what
you got it works when you do those me
now I mean you can't get them they're
sold out but I mean on the on the
second-hand market you're looking about
a grand that is not a killer [ __ ] I've
ever seen and where do you wear those
Wow where are you highlighting I mean
usually so you remember how to get back
home you can wear you know on stage
wherever man come on the other work I'm
all about matching to a point I don't
know what you match that stuff to me
like you wear that what you like I could
wear with this outfit you went black you
wear this with your big bird outfit they
go with your big bird suit Chris would
get off stage and like women will come
to the comedy store dressed like they're
going to a nightclub so when he would
get off stage yeah he would go to the to
the I'm watching go to the go to the
patio and they would present them yes
like lines of pageant yeah to get dig
down they love him who's gonna get the
dick down by the king and that I would
just watch it happens yeah and again you
could get that point we're like [ __ ]
this dude getting all the [ __ ] oh you'd
be like dude that dude is getting all
the women love them they love daylily
love him yep I'm really jealous get some
convention sure hey dude I also have a
tour coming yeah tell us about your tour
I'm due to tour with Brody Stephens jim
Florentine my friend Chad sumac and
we're going through Texas and we're
doing it's called the social justice
warriors tour you guys got to see this
they're not social justice wounds or not
San Antonio were there Thursday December
14th
we're at the blind tiger then San Marcos
Friday December 15th at aqua blue and
then Houston Saturday December 16th at
the
seeker group and then on Sunday December
17th we are at Austin at the cap city
comedy club okay
cup cup I love me some cap city - I
gotta get them where's your favorite
place a cap see is one of them why it
used to be for Thor tale improv because
I love Miami
I love anywhere in Miami I love Florida
I'm headlining the Tampa Bay Improv on
New Year's I love to every time I go
Tampa but I could move here I love
Calgary I love Yuk Yuk's and Calgary is
great - I love I've had amazing shows
that comedy works in Vancouver anywhere
in Canada is always killer Toronto is
the [ __ ] Rondo is like San Francisco
with [ __ ] people and cleaner right
you're like oh you're all smart I could
talk about and hot your hat and your
[ __ ] a great food yeah love Toronto
they're clean it's just a difference
mini New York yeah yeah but cleaner
have you ever seen this club called the
comedy corner it's literally in the
throttle it's this 20 seat Club it's
like this tiny ass Club but it's [ __ ]
great that's wrong my friend Joe owns it
it's like 20 seats you're like what the
[ __ ] is this and you just go in and it's
[ __ ] it's in Toronto yeah let me see
it that's that's cool it's called a
comedy corner I love those little places
yeah dude it's great oh it was great
yeah there's the kind of things you
don't need a mic with you can just get
up and start talking yeah it's a tiny
ass [ __ ] Club no 20 paper corner
comedy club that'd be a great place to
shoot a special oh my god that's cool
that's so [ __ ] tiny and look how
white and happy they are happy crowd
with one asian chick yep right she's
great in the middle oh I see and there's
one in the back 270 good time there's
one find the minorities here on fire
tonight what do you got gin all right go
see Sam Tripoli can they get the tickets
in free tour I did go to my website
santafeford.com I have mala listed there
I people TR i pol SA MTR i pol I and I'm
sure you post on your Instagram yes and
I would love for you guys come on my
conspiracy podcast and we'll just try to
pop a couple things open see what you
guys think all right Tim Foyle how
mobile minded adachin I know it's not
yeah that's
I'll be good you need somebody like me
who says I love it who says no to all
conspiracies that's great that's great
I'm not that I don't believe people are
conspiratorial I'm in the middle I
believe someone super shady and I
believe some of the people are levels to
this [ __ ] all right and there's you
gotta go white belt all the way up to
triple Bluff so there's there's Bryan
Callen Eddie Bravo them in the middle
yeah and like the white belt shades you
start off with who shot JFK and from
there we can move on to what do you want
to look into something I'm not really
gonna get into Flat Earth lizard be
aliens I mean like I'm never gonna be
able to prove any of that [ __ ] okay but
I will talk where we can talk money and
power and how it crop into that and who
is what who wants that power who wants
to keep that pop you brat or thought I
agree that I agree with ya that's people
what percentage of conspiracy do you
believe it I go that's not it there's
levels to this can I bring a tinfoil hat
like the movie signs yeah there are
there are conspiracies just really hard
to get away with it in our government
because it's so incompetent well I don't
talk about that yeah there are people
that come forward and they get demonized
the rut life's get ruined or they get
killed so people and like as you go up
this ladder like I just did Bert
Chrysler's podcast right and we talked
about my favorite people crack epidemic
and how a lot of people believe it was
done systematically by the government
okay - I had Rick Ross on my desk well
which Rick Ross rapper the real real he
stole his yeah Rick I need him for yeah
and you know Rick Ross the rapper was a
cop before stole that guy's whole
persona everything I cancer so I had him
on and they talked about he's moving
like a million dollars worth of crack a
day like that's how much it was going
and he was getting it through the CIA
and that's you know I mean that's and
it's pretty much seen as a fact at this
point you know I Ryan and it's I I had
him on my podcast it's systematic it's
systematic right and he goes well why
why would they why would they agree to
that why would they why wouldn't someone
go hey why are we doing this to the
black community go because when you make
it to that level
you
in you don't ask that you don't get
allowed in there unless you're already
cool with that [ __ ] and it's called okay
I feel like I'm losing Brian but the
point is the initiating people have
always been able to get high and I think
they've always been criminal interests
like the drug cartels in Mexico and
Altos bar R Bar sure they have I'm sure
they have I'm sure that the law
enforcement will cut deals with
criminals so they can get the bigger
fish blah-blah-blah-blah and I also
believe that law enforcement whether
it's CIA whether it's DEA whether has
criminal elements within it small row
groups like the rampart division that
take advantage that get caught that
don't get caught that are part of the
drug trade I believe that 100 percent
just like in Mexico right just like
there's a lot of federal and state
corruption in Mexico 100 percent right
now that's that that is a hundred
percent true okay so let's look at the
Comedy Store let's say the government is
the Comedy Store okay right Brian
Joe Rogan has his clique crystally as
his clique christian edwards has his
clique Eric Griffin has his clique they
don't necessarily know what the other
ones are doing but they're all at the
Comedy Store
yeah does that mean that none of them
have shady ideas and it's not that they
all know there are rogue elements I have
no doubt that the our government
elements of our government saw money to
be made you had a group of dudes who are
like you know what we're never gonna
stop this it should probably be legal
anyway or whatever as an example and
they went why don't we get in on it and
one of the things I'm surprised at is
that people for the most part in law
enforcement are pretty ethical because a
lot of them don't do it most of them
don't and I'm always surprised let me
give you an example if I'm a cop and I
think I'm a good guy and I walk in and
there's a hundred million dollars in
cash on a bed we go in sizzler I'm gonna
have a hard time not pocketing yeah at
least a little because it's illegal
money I give a 40 grand a year right my
life on them but you know what most of
them don't and there are a lot of
systems there's a galas play but it's
pretty much a game that's played the
people that are involved
look for signs that you're willing to
play ball and they do that [ __ ] I'm not
saying that it is like
I mean that's really memorable at all
yeah a lot of magic no cop it's the
chaos that would be our obese crew so
it's like people like go comfort cops
aren't bad people just like anything
well Trevor Noah said Trevor Noah Trevor
Noah said something great on Daily Show
he said the one thing I can't understand
about you Americans is why you have to
be either on one team or another why do
you have to be all over here so can you
not believe that black lives matter but
also like cops why can't you have both
that's why man which you can you can
it's okay dude again rone in that [ __ ] I
don't join groups man unless I like I'll
join your group because I know you too
and I know the integrity you two have so
I'll go to [ __ ] more for you [ __ ]
cats you know but it's like if I don't
[ __ ] know you I'm not gonna go out
there and fight with people I'm [ __ ]
now I know people block their family
members because they like Trump it's
like that's your mom that you're cold
these are your views I know that I you
don't know this mom I like I do bit
about it's like well you know we are the
Republicans think this of Hillary and
the blah blah blah think this a [ __ ]
Trump I'm like you only think we know in
life in politics is that Melania Trump
is the Michael Jordan of gold diggers
like she is the greatest to [ __ ] old
creepy powerful man so hot dude she went
from third world to the first lady that
he's a lot of dicks you've got a suck
homeboy or she's just or she's just
again very strategic and maybe only did
it with three guys but she's [ __ ]
smart could she be any hotter for a
forty five-year-old
and I'd love everyone gets mad at like
her nudie pics it's like so the [ __ ] it
was very tasteful new depicts number one
I've never seen it
she's the first lady goddamn it Oh gives
a [ __ ] I think she's she holds with some
Russian stuff but she handles herself
well this is a this is an Eastern
European
do beauty she's a loose she's a woman
she's a very elegant woman man the
easiest way is gorgeous up the hierarchy
look at her she's untouchable of society
is to be a hot chick look at her but
she's also she's also classy she's
composed she gives nothing away she's a
woman man she's a [ __ ] woman
you gotta get interesting I won't get
when the Republicans are in the first
lady's very quiet and when the
Democrats in the first lady has a very
big personality interesting liberal
versus conservative it's very
traditional traditional versus new
Hillary and Michele versus Laura Bush
and a good point it's very interesting
great observations man that's so true
you're so right about that man
unbelievable yeah it sounds like the
plot de Blasio's wife the mayor of New
York
his wife is black with dreads she used
to be gay and now she's his wife and
she's like [ __ ] oh yeah have you ever
been with a lesbian they're like oh I've
only been with my half of that and
you're like I feel like Jackie Robinson
like I'm the first of my people to be
allowed and if I don't show up my people
get shut out for the rest of the [ __ ]
life my boy right oh my god dude I got
represent not [ __ ] up for you're
gonna love this my boy my boy Jimmy
Burke as you know jr. I there was a
waitress at shutters she was so that I
first moved here she was so beautiful
and she in LA yes and she was I was like
obsessed and I was like aah and I and I
I just would go in and I would talk to
her and finally one day I asked her to
come on a hike with me and I and my
whole gym he was in town and so he came
on the hike with us and we were walking
and that night we had sex but it was
really I just it was just I was like was
she a lesbian bro well I'll tell you so
I go I was like it wasn't there like I
was like I don't know what's going on
here are you so hard it was just going
on this move no it was not only it was
causing this was I feeling it yeah and
even when we're hiking as we're hiking I
was like five myself gone she's so hot
but there's she was something yeah man
something out there yeah something like
so I saw I stated to me I go sex just
wasn't there and he goes that's because
you know Jimmy Berto Fugger's well Bubba
that's because she's a handsome young
man and I go what do you mean because if
you don't didn't pick up the fact that
she's as gay as gay
and you seem to be some experiment than
my friend you don't read human beings
really sure enough the next day she goes
you're the first guy I've actually ever
been with I'm gay and I was like [ __ ]
you from birth but Claire outta yourself
yeah it was just I'm surprised she laid
it down for you it was just off ah it
was off and she goes you're singing your
frequencies were off it frequencies were
totally off she's not even she wasn't
she's bought used to being alpha and
throw the other girl around she's like
whoa what's yes she was she also just
liked me and I think she was like let me
see what this is about
no she did not she was like and she was
like I've never that dick is huge your
body so shredded and yeah okay she
didn't say that but I remember feeling
awkward I remember feeling like I never
hooked up again I never hooked up with
her again and in New York there was
another gig gig gorgeous gal she had a
German Shepherd and she was wealthy her
dad had crazy money Egyptian and
something else and I again again I was
like the [ __ ] is going on with this and
she said to me she goes we I would come
over and something would and she finally
goes you might be my first boyfriend and
I go yeah what does that mean what does
that [ __ ] mean she goes well this is
who I dated before she held at this
picture of this ridiculously hot girl
she goes I'm basically gay interest yeah
and I felt it I felt the vibe well hey
you and I have a friend recently
recently ladies and gentlemen where I
showed up to meet him before my set at
The Improv and this woman was jacked
I mean tits ass mouth I was like laughs
oh yeah she looked like a blow-up doll I
was like that is that is obscene but I'm
just very turned on and and he said I
but they were again we're sitting there
talking here yeah good she was very
sexual and she was like saying stuff
about how cute I was like I'm older but
hot and I was like Jesus all right I
just met you but okay drinks please come
come watch me sitting down she's kind of
touching my buddy and I something was up
and I said to three people
I went do you feel there's something
going on with that person and they went
I do and I don't know what it is a girl
of a girl I go they go I do
I said what are you thinking easy is it
just seems that they are I don't know if
that's a guy I don't know if that used
to be a guy and I went you can't tell
nobody doing I see these chicks are like
bro my buddy
to do my buddy my dick just got true but
he said two things my buddy said two
things about it he said I just and he's
dog but he goes I just wasn't wrong I
couldn't she was there I was talking her
she's hot
he was her skin the temperature bottom
was different I know and he said and and
she smelled she smelled different she
smelled smell it was not it was not
smelled internally liked I got a Dewar's
out she's felt like he was approached
she was a trans transexual she had had
her put the full operation and
everything hot but they were joining us
something not even how was the sex and
he didn't do it he didn't do it
you scared she said she said to him you
know she said to him she felt it you
know she said you know I'm you know how
I said I used to be a guy she said you
know it said I'm a lot like a guy
sometimes and he said I know what you
mean and then she said well give me a
call whenever sometimes oh yeah I know
she was so sweet there's some trans
girls were like days on it's great like
holy yeah oh [ __ ] my dick [ __ ] it yes
sir that's all right what do you got Jim
of course you will I and I know you're
being serious and I appreciate that
about you I know have you had it before
so I'm a shady ass [ __ ] have you
had it before though yes I have oh you
have yeah god bless you for that I have
a 1 1 a 5 dude I'm like yeah what about
a straight dude what about like have you
had just a dude do it no no no I'm not
that freaky yeah it's got a trick the
[ __ ] system do you know what I'm
saying all right if you want to go here
I gotta tell a story there's a faith as
an actor I'll tell you afterwards I'm
not gonna tell you who he is
actor comic I'm doing MADtv well one of
our our hair people who I love very much
was was that was the first transsexual
I'd ever met and had the operation I
think in the second year of MADtv and
she had always felt like a woman always
when she was 13 taking her brothers but
her sisters she was when she was a boy
taking her sister's birth control pills
she always felt it deeply deeply
she had a very hot very hot transsexual
friend who had a pierced tongue and big
just she was just up astonishingly hot
now this used to be a still hover dick I
know she did not sir she back then those
Donnison no no no sir she did not and
she was astonishing I'm by the way this
is 1997 yeah I think sure that's weird
to think back this and I remember
looking her but you knew you knew she
was used to be but just I mean delicious
big just for its faster okay and my
buddy my buddy goes bro I think she's
hot as [ __ ] and I go I know and he goes
no no man I think she's [ __ ] we have
a thing they went in to we were on stage
I can't let him tell the story on on in
you know in the big hangar you have
dressing rooms there just like that and
they go in and she's gonna do his makeup
and they're in there as he's changing
because we got a hurry up so as you're
changing they're doing your makeup and
there's just they're in there they're in
there and he comes out and I look down
in his pants and he's got his a
weathered house dick is Tenten it's ten
foot but drain it's drained but tent
yeah feels like hang clothes still there
because right Bob it hasn't it hasn't
pulled back in yet and I looked at him
and I go I go I just look there he goes
yep I did yup I did he gave me the
finger and kept walking I think it's
more than God bless you I hate more
people have done it then anybody will
ever [ __ ] shower I think it's way out
looking for it though Sam back then no
his hat you're just like oh cool there's
a pair of balls no it's just they don't
have my dick well some do it's not all
think your fantasy they do well no some
of them do there's a lot of shadiness
out there I'm a weirdo so I I'm just
gotten to the point is it a weird other
or is it that she looks like a weirdo
not the norm not that's not normal it's
not the norm and it's just like society
like even in midian I felt like the room
just got really quiet not two-second I
mean it is what I'm an old man yeah I'm
like I don't give a [ __ ] to sleep I'm
really at that place so it's like
whatever you you bang guys and that's
what this whole podcast is that's what
comes out of this so be a dog I don't
give a [ __ ] maybe it'll open a car I
can't even get arrested in Hollywood I
got a car crash they didn't even do a
breathalyzer on me they're like you're
[ __ ] good I'm like at least test me
dude act like I mattered ah you're good
dog time on that please [ __ ] give me
a goddamn breathalyzer there are women
there are there are men who are now
women that will fool the [ __ ] out of you
and that I would argue most men I know
straight guys sure I don't care you
there I think what you do sexually
should be about as much as a it should
define you as much as you bring your II
did well hey you know I'm saying I love
you just live in trans models wallace
Beery ever really it's gonna be it's
gonna [ __ ] be crazy
no well I don't I've no idea I've never
resources now nope dead listen Mandarin
yeah look at that black girl look at all
of them we'll take it easy but look at
that wow that she's on now I met her
she's on oh [ __ ]
yeah energy meter she's a big room she's
a big girl
well yeah no that's the other one that's
one from oranges boy yeah yeah we're
uncocks yes huh
I'd hit it I'd hit it I'd hit it then
I'd hit it honey purse now Wow
hold on keep going technologies I hate
one that's cross-eyed look at that
cross-eyed one I made the cross I jump
out the cot has my food oh not another
cockeyed one the dude go chin go -
what's going on yeah dude well that's
Laverne alright alright it's all good
dog I'm gonna pass on a cockeyed one
those in there at all all of them I prep
em you go down to that one down there
and the
Brown right there that little cutiepie
when your kids are grown
everyone's gonna be biased but I I'll
date her right now but these might not
be transgender that might be a real
model okay oh yeah she her last name is
trans and if my wife says so great
you're so great know what dude you know
what you know what if that's it
I will date her right now Oh go out on a
limb the maxim model you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna have I'm gonna I'm
gonna have an affair with a couple
trends models and I'm gonna do it only
if my wife says [ __ ] I'm gonna say it's
a dude it used to be a dude stop being a
baby about things and I'm going through
a phase and I don't want to hear it and
I bet you she'll understand all right
Jim woody got for you keep going out
that used to be a guy I have that was a
woman I make out with a woman I'll make
out with her right now hit model sir
well it's a guy
her middle name is trans thank Lee it's
a trance all right Jimmy I'm making out
with her hey speaking of Jake's auntie
puck Tupac's ex-girlfriend has a picture
of his piece and she's selling it for
7,500 doesn't look that big in that
picture maybe you know he's black how do
you sign hard dude what do you want it
goes outside this though yeah that's
fair I courted Bob Jim what if that
wasn't sick those were just as nuts
hanging and he's got little stumped
maybe nobody nobody can visit our first
big pitch ever
they were saying that in this article
about the dick pic dude you know when
they invented the camera the first thing
they did was take a picture of a naked
chick yes heard the guy even bet they
all with Mego took a picture in his head
his girlfriend look what I invented and
you look down since [ __ ] dick true
you know Megan old dick pics we had to
paint it Oh
bushes just bushes that's all they had
back then man that's interesting I'd
like to see it without the mm-hmm what
yeah yeah I see what he's working with
you want to see his dick yeah Tommy and
Brennan care about what that's all we
care how dare you judge me say you dick
sucked by dudes bro okay dude I'm eatin
dude the first time
my first time is I swear to god he
craned his Mongoose neck over that
barrier and I looked up I guess he was
interested me I don't even know him that
well he just had that giant Mongoose
neck and he was he was crying over with
no shame and I looked at it was like
what are you doing man he goes
don't be weird I'm just making sure I'm
just checking out what you will talk to
big guys I got I gotta see what kind of
cat yeah yeah yep
so did you ever happy to after that I
should have you should have what else
Jetson
alright Sports one Altea well this says
if you fights Joshua he wants it to be
an equal pay fifty-fifty it's not
happening it's not happening because
Joshua just has too much power he's the
big draw it's tough because with Hearns
who's Joshua's promoter they're just not
gonna bend down to that yeah like and
don't get me wrong
Joshua Parker's no Deontay Wilder as far
as Fame and is you mean he's a great
fighter John - well there's no Joshua no
no Joshua Parker so to fall here Joshua
Parker's then they got from New Zealand
who's a world champion writer he's
supposed to fight Anthony Joshua negs
okay who's Joshua Parker and Anthony
Joshua's the Briton okay so Joshua
Parker wanted 5050 in that I mean
they're not you know that's not [ __ ]
happen
so he had to back down as alright we'll
figure it out because Joshua was just
he's the biggest name in boxing now so
besides Canelo so he's calling the shot
what do you think of it sellout in
America became him fought here I feel
like he's big over the pond and Wilder's
big over here and they fight somewhere
in the middle like Antarctica or some
[ __ ] like that
yeah those bring their bleep with the
promise Dion say I was gonna have to go
to Wembley Stadium he's gonna have to
fight him in the UK and then they'll do
it here now which are they both great
they're obviously champions but their
style are they great boxers or they just
big dudes who could throw great boxers
they're great boxer the world's filled
of big dudes again throw these to me and
I gotta beat beat yeah it was one of the
most actors my favorite horrified of all
time but you both medalists in the
Olympics as well yeah yeah let me ask
you this guy
just knocked out over him his managers
like in a couple years I like to see him
fight these guys he's [ __ ] crazy
these guys would I do think he's crazy
but but if you actually did a no-rules
who'd win that fight Francis would walk
through them like he can do anything
takedown yeah I mean like he'd beat them
in like a minute stand about this
arguments like it was maybe send out
it's like saying how would Tom Brady do
if you put him on the ice think I don't
[ __ ] know I mean they're both it I
don't think it's that different because
it is though like I don't who gives a
[ __ ] is it such a different sport right
it is it though with the water pools
guys drawing regular polo it is striking
it is striking and what you see is that
you know you see these boxers calling up
these UFC fighters like they're bad they
want notoriety and fame because no
that's back to our media thing it's all
about cliques and all that [ __ ] but
that's a prime people this is about like
if there were rules for this no those
are the two highest level heavyweight
boxers in the world right now they
should 100% fight they will fight it's
just figuring out that deal
how Sawyer is that wilder than you used
to know you've spent time six six Joshua
six five okay they're both complete
monsters giant that's a great fight he
might be sick seven I see that Charlie
as much as much as you know Francis in
Ghana you know everyone's time I know he
would you'd be you would even be a
middle tier professional boxer guys
don't realize the difference between
he's a monster though the UFC okay
Anthony Joshua's my monster oh oh man
that hit on only justice I just just put
Francis in the Olympic Trials and he
wouldn't make it out of it
little lone compete with these
professionals I just just different men
yeah I know it's a did I hear you I get
the argument all the time it's a god be
it was like well dude that's with rules
for this [ __ ] yeah it was just straight
up just fight anything goes I think he
walked through them I know I just
you see people calling our Connor all
the time like Garcia I'll [ __ ] you I'll
knock him out I'm like in the boxing
ring you would I mean it's like real
[ __ ] talking
but you know there's got to be some
rules for your advantage and that's what
Connor said you know and that he's like
this was a real fight I would bash your
skull in no prob you'd last 15 seconds
well yeah that last [ __ ] fight was
amazing which one that card was to 18 or
to 17 to 18 amazing card low numbers
lowest numbers ever for prelims what
yeah well also what's going on was that
day huge college football games like all
the conference championship all the
championships so I mean I was going back
and forth koto people freaked out you
know koto put he was free on HBO
they pulled 900 7000 so that hurts it a
little bit and it's like by I think it's
also and they've compete this is what
the US he does they compete with the
biggest of the bigs and they've always
done well this has been our last year
ever I think I think it's on the
promotional the work they're just not
doing the work well I think that's a lot
of stuff it's like you know comedy clubs
do that a lot too it's like you know
it's like you guys sell out but
sometimes I'll go to clubs and they'll
do any promotion zero yeah yeah and then
they're like we'll get the difference
between the laugh act in the Comedy
Store the economy stores social media is
a I tell everybody bows pictures hat you
have to attack then you look at the
other places that aren't doing well I'm
like take notes from the comedy improv
puts out the shows like three hours
before the show that it doesn't read kit
that you got too much ash too many
options for you to post something three
hours before and think people history I
don't know why UFC doesn't go heavy
during the summer that's when you should
go heavy cuz you're up against baseball
well they have their big card in July
4th but then you have boom boom and then
lighter what's your writer cuz every all
the big sports are going well what they
what I think they do with their business
model is they're gonna have to fold a
lot of paper using you're gonna get six
major paper views a year and then you
get good cards on regular TV and here's
the truth fan and it's like when people
start seeing that the employees aren't
being treated well there is a reaction
to that and except with Apple phones but
yet you know I get you to that too and
that's a nice a hold others and that's a
whole nother story okay but in terms of
like within the United States like
Walmart took a little hit because
people like nobodies they're not paying
people so they're like eh I'm not gonna
go there and they saw it happen so they
did this campaign at the put now I think
you see with the NFL with these
concussions and how they treat these
guys you see it start to wane a little
bit UFC I think they really need to go
they need to see the money increase for
these fighters so that one better
athletes start coming to it and then
people get I think behind it more the
more when you hear these guys aren't
making money or they're you know you see
boxes that you haven't heard of making
couple middle fight and I know the model
is different but and you hear these guys
like when someone saw the Anderson Silva
in a fight he made from a Reebok got
$5,000 sponsorship money so [ __ ]
terrible people like [ __ ] that you look
a little bit like Anthony Joshua it's
good-looking dude I'll think we just
realize that in a hat congratulation
doesn't Brendan look a little bit like
yeah you guys lookin dude he does
African American yeah that's fine but
you're in America I might be um you know
what's not taking a hit though and it's
more corrupt than UFC Apple Nike any of
these companies are referring to you
know it's the most corrupt business in
the United States I know can I say NC
double-a college football dude it is an
illness dick college football numbers
every basketball kill it that's why was
only good in March but for a college
football dude if you're watching college
basketball is the greatest season I've
seen the amount of talent in the EM in
the NCAA right now is mind-blowing cuz
we are seven years in to this Golden
State Warriors experiment where
everybody's can shoot and now you're
seeing these kids who grew up watching
this stuff and you see seven footers
from half you shoot just drain or they
heard this day I heard that basketball
is like changing that the players are
not as bulky because it's become more of
a game where you're shooting from the
inside man really does it yeah it's just
different no it's more shooting with
Joel embiid you've seen a guy who went
back to an old school style cuz he's
huge but what you're now the true
there's eras there's the Bill Russell
Wilt Chamberlain era will say that they
didn't allow what black guy
then we got the Larry Bird Magic Johnson
era and that went all the way to the
Miami big three and that was more about
individuals Michael Jordan created that
where it's like I got all these
endorsements and all the [ __ ] right the
new era is the Golden State Warriors -
like what I call the Milwaukee Bucks era
where it's like everybody can shoot you
the six or seven a dude sets everybody's
can be seven footers they can also shoot
from like half-court like courier just
pulled from half-court what the [ __ ]
dude but NFL's changing to college
football's do a lot of it like like a
running back everything's action
I told ball I said I'm pretty drunk I'm
gonna do a sports podcast with Jason
Tebow Ari Shaffir I said the running
back will make a comeback because these
linebackers have to get smaller so they
can cover these huge tight ends that are
running out for [ __ ] passes yeah and
then it toll now you see all these great
running backs let me cast really
interesting they find that word yeah
that [ __ ] changes the dynamic like the
for a while the big receiver was in the
6 6 240 Calvin Johnson was in and then
now the slot West the West welcome why'd
that happen
success right team should get really
good now we want that everybody's
because the defense then counters for
the large method and now they go well
let's use a gun ok double cover him we
have the small guy be work use me [ __ ]
[ __ ] the James Harrow since the 275 line
back SIA are gone you think I ought to
cover these can't cover [ __ ] these
these Gronkowski guys who are just these
monsters running down the Midway and
catching ball yeah it's it's the
evolution of the sport we are watching
basketball
it's like MMA remember MMA there are
specialists there's like the Chuck
Liddell's and then there was the judo or
the Jiu Jitsu guys now it's like you
gotta be everything or else you got no
chance no just one of the one of the
guys who came to my show in Utah plays
for their team I don't know what it's
jazz not to jazz not he's college he's
college oh you tell you to use I'm Vicki
and he's Maggie's 272 all states 270 and
easy looking dish all muscle nothing he
said that they want him yeah and they
said he's six nine to seventy and they
they
want him to lose weight he goes I'm all
muscle you know he's like he's not a lot
to lose but he said because of the way
the game has changed being a big man on
the inside is not as valuable as being
on the outside sure he depends yeah you
know if you're a beast
it was like Joel embiid changing that I
mean like the guys going for 35 and 15
every monster that what they're relating
him to Hakeem Olajuwon
and he's Shaq big now the 76ers are
gonna have like it's gonna be like they
have shafts bettin simmons is a lonesome
young LeBron James and this new kid
marques faults is like loss Westbrook
imagine that's all on one team now
they're talking about where's LeBron
James gonna go mention if he goes to the
76ers they're all I'm Ricky contract
except for one guy Joel embiid so now if
you're LeBron James I'm like I'm gonna
go this guy I'm still the best player in
the league but the worst I'll get on
this team as time goes on I'll become
the fourth best guy on this team and
they're all murderers so I'm gonna be
able to may I there's a chance he could
go past LeBron James if you go on Joel
embiid Ben Simmons marques false team
for the next ten years you're competing
for [ __ ] championship but they're all
they're also guys that it wasn't like
this at least these super teams that
they just got from free agent they
actually drafted they taint you know
officer they suck season JJ Watt who's
300 pounds look that was smaller than
that guy that guy is where you like well
Jordana to Bay makes sense Altuve cuz
he's five seven yeah but boy wait look
at Jay look at who's Joel and be that
guy fixer we're talking when the best
part was that guy that guy look at the
size of him we may be sure monitored
he's as funny as [ __ ] bro he's he's
dwarfing JT but he's a basketball player
I still look at the size of him it's
[ __ ] on dick Ulis now here's the
thing dude what we're seeing what these
guys are getting drafted so early at
19th are all getting hurt because you
know football you got away three years
to get into the NFL
cuz physically you're not big enough to
take those hits different gaming too but
dude in the NBA people think it's a
[ __ ] touch but League dunno it is I
mean Chris Paul have you ever seen Chris
Paul he's six foot brick [ __ ] he
gets [ __ ] grinded all the time it's a
grown man's Lee shoot these guys are
coming into the league 19 years old
getting [ __ ] up just not yet they're
just not man yet so everybody yells that
they should be allowed to go rate from
high school - no no no no no you got to
come up with a system where they can get
drafted but not go to the NBA make money
so they can give their family go like I
wanted that MB deal was it the nbda well
it's called the G Lee the Gatorade
League but I want to be where they can
go they can do their college basketball
season get Matt Duke or wherever and
then once that seasons done they can get
called up to the major leagues and plate
like it's baseball style so you base
your blade yeah like you get called up
and you ride the bench or they see if
you go and then at the end of a
basketball season you go back to college
for one more year you learn what you got
to work on
it'd be cool you've gotten realistic but
with the n-c-double-a they got to change
your the hallway after they have to
change making that much money man dude
and stop with the amateur sports
[ __ ] I know nothing that makes a
billion dollars it's amateur [ __ ] but
they call it amateur sports but then the
cell you know this this the the
quarterback for Oklahoma the cell
history these Hyden will make millions
millions do nothing do commercial you
paid nothing
what yeah right money nothing you know
you don't need it I don't go over you
get an education [ __ ] that is
intangible what can they do to change
this like what is that what is the
course about too deep the tentacles are
too deep you won't have to go you have
to participate in this darkness in order
to get to the NFL so it's never gonna
change
it's just so much money in it it's not
good for a player oh right to the enemy
is there a way to come don't you start I
don't know you use this you start with
them with Fairplay a class-action suit
shaming I mean a lot of different ways
to kind of go hey guys you're making
money guys to have so many guys have but
like okay don't come to Stanford okay go
JUCO we don't give a [ __ ]
Wow cuz guess what there's 1 million
other guys can catch this footballers
throw the football go don't the MB the
NCAA am being easy and that's was a
little different basketball is a little
different because there's not so many
guys you know there's 12 guys on the
team the chance of you make the NBA
out of colleges do not 420 people in the
world are in the NBA
I may get drafted war here think about
an always a 64 people so you know your
[ __ ] brother you just say oh you're so
Sam's so sick Sam 64 get drafted if
you're deaf in the second round chance
are you making a team not good remember
there's only 12 guys on team you have to
hope you outplay one of those vets to
get on the team there's four really all
around make it to 420 players some of
those spots are taken up by Kobe Bryant
for 20 years correct that's that's 20
years that spot is not open so and then
you got these guaranteed contracts so
most of the team there's 12 those are
guaranteed contracts so the actual
chances of jumping on any is impossible
now try being a quarterback in the NFL
try being a quarterback in the NFL where
there's 32 teams and then it's the
hardest job in the world
there's one spots or maybe maybe 300 and
every year there's six rounds of draft
picks and look how many guys turn out to
be decent quarterback yet it's [ __ ]
impossible
well you don't try being a kicker in the
league there's thirty two kickers in the
world they stay there for [ __ ] ever
is it weird that they also like they're
trying to legislate out the kicking
which is weird cuz it's called football
it's like you're gonna get rid of the
following nobody
how many quarterbacks deep do you go as
a team third string fourth - usually we
usually at three though no a lot of
hoarder back just spent two to three to
do oh you know what see you drive
depends on drive or you don't have a
fourth string no no there's sometimes
most teams left three but that third
guys the practice right guy yeah and if
all [ __ ] fails yeah you mean you've gone
through some shan't start the third guys
not playing it down until somebody gets
killed two people get hurt yeah and
usually they'll bring in another guy
before they have to throw that to him
and be like a receiver vent quarterback
in college or some [ __ ] right or they'll
call some guy up sitting on his couch
Testaverde still yeah yeah and it's
crazy because they kept talking about
Kaepernick getting in now here's the
thing about Kaepernick dude like I feel
bad for him but he literally did this to
himself he renegotiated his contract to
take less my
and less years so he could get the free
agency quicker and he can play and I go
when he did I go you are going to regret
this you never leave money on the table
and the best exists sometimes it pays
off he's a guy named Shawn Kemp who used
to play for the sick
we used to play for the super Sox got
trade so I believe 11 children out of
wedlock oh by the way great dogs is that
Dwight Howard is that - yes [ __ ] 90
kids but he's so good-looking and so big
he should probably breed a lot like I'm
fine with it too but what we're talking
it's like you're gonna go broke so Shawn
Kemp went to Cleveland then he got
traded to Portland and he took off
he agreed to a buyout leaving three
years on the table unlike 40 million
dollars and he never got it back cuz he
thought he was gonna ball out in
Portland I was gonna ball out somewhere
he wanted out part in basketball leases
guarantee guaranteed money for
Kaepernick to do that with his style
which is a running style plant being
athletic they're gonna shut that down
eventually if nothing's guaranteed so
far we go now I'll take my chances it's
[ __ ] idiotic but he starts playing
bad then now he's playing and I'm not
saying what he's doing is right or wrong
then he starts playing the race role now
he's more relevant and current his girl
I got her to do that [ __ ] she call a
relevant current than ever then he's
more he's talked about more these days
on the SPN than Tom Brady even though
Tom Brady they never do they're not
they're never gonna let him back in
never gonna be in he's never gonna come
back it's not just because his stance on
black lives and all that stuff a lot of
has to do with he's not that good well
it's also dude I hate to tell everybody
Sports is a corporate gig it is his job
yeah she got him in [ __ ] trouble dude
she's the one he was gonna say
censorship she was he was gonna get
signed by the Ravens and she put out a
picture of arm of Diego Diego and [ __ ]
what's to do and chain was that movie
here and going Django Unchained yeah
right and they had basically the picture
of the slave owner in the slave and she
said it was and that's how he got in
trouble was the owner of the Baltimore
Ravens Ray Lulu
said they so the whole team so Regulus
is like advisor for the Ravens right
right NFL great a hashtag murder but so
he's in on the front office they're
about to sign Kaepernick his girlfriend
releases that tweet and the manager goes
we can't do it yeah we can't do it now
he's about to get signed and here's he's
alive the problem is he's a liability he
is he's to duties cuz also not that good
well whether it is the reason people
stopped watching which I don't think it
is no I don't think of this he got
blamed for it they're not watching her
sport we also just won the Mohammed all
lead sportsman of the year here's the
thing on the front cover of Time
magazine I'm gonna make you a prediction
as soon as it dies out in terms of
people time by them she's gonna dump him
I see happen all the time
in the NFL you see it all the time in a
slider
she is ridiculous really is what is he
looking a fatass to what what is his
nationality he is biracial he was
adopted by white parents grew up no
touchie grew up white privilege in
Nevada boy did not grow up you know yeah
well look at that g-tube dude Ice Cube
what two pair of very rich to pay as
daddies that was bus driver but but cube
grew up there's cubes parents he came
tight family and his father and his
mother he didn't come from money but
they sent him out of the hood and they
he went to a different school okay is
that okay thing you have to grow up on
the streets to stand for black lives
anything like that but I don't know it's
a problem with any kind of social
justice warriors you don't know if these
people are one being honest with who
they are and they don't know what you
don't know where they're coming from
either so you just don't [ __ ] know
I'm just over I just think that's like I
think you should be able to see I mean
it's a corporate gig dude if you were on
[ __ ] you know if you did that on the
Goldbergs what would they [ __ ] do you
know it's just like you lose your dumb
yes it's just the way these are
corporate gigs man yeah and then it goes
back to the news it was what you were
saying
but no it goes back to those advertisers
like the 49ers you're talking about
coca-cola Levi's yes these major
corporations that you represent being
the leader of the team and they go
listen we're putting up all the money
for the Levi's Stadium we're doing this
we can't be associated with that so you
figure it out
not to mention he's not Tom Brady he's
not winning games we have why the [ __ ]
are we even do you look the way I look
at is it that he has every right to do
what he did I said wouldn't you have to
take responsibility for the
ramifications and in this country not
only can ya know I can you you can take
a knee but also people have a right to
boycott you and so it goes both ways you
know yeah I'm sorry that he's just never
gonna get back in the league but is that
he's gonna be fine though you're saying
it's a function of two things one too
much controversy too just not good
enough
I'd say lean more towards too much
controversy I think it's way more good
enough to play an NFL should be on a
team Brandon Weeden still was like being
considered for quarterbacking and that
guy and god bless him dude hey man he
gone farther than I would ever go in the
NFL but he's just isn't an NFL
quarterback and you know a nice guy I'm
sure I wish him nothing but love in the
world but he was already getting people
are calling him up to see if I'm I would
take capra Kaepernick over Brock
Osweiler controversy yeah that no one
wants to deal with Tim Tebow you know
and not so much a negative limelight but
Tim Tebow dealt with this where so many
teams go could he play for us yes
does our front office want to deal with
all that comes with him because as soon
as the starter those interception Tim
Tebow is so liked they're gonna be
chanting his name which is a distraction
for the for the team so we don't want
take that well I'm a guy who's just as
good or maybe not as good and we'd have
to deal with Vince Young both have
winning records and that's all they can
see Vince Young had a winning record and
it's just he's good on the Titans and at
some point they just decide you're just
too much of a distraction and it's the
supply is why I mean the demand the
supply is way over the demand and they
don't they don't need to deal with they
just don't need to headache they go what
no we're out we're out we're out we'll
get a guy who's not asking
versal maybe then run as well what deal
we'll figure yeah yeah thank us what
else you got general that girl that we
talked about before that tried to look
like Angelina Jolie with 50 surgeries is
that a real base so that's not that was
a mask well I mean let's play this rope
wait she so that's all right so she
talked to a Russian newspaper cuz no one
still knows exactly what's going on but
apparently it's all fake she just was
really good at computers Wow
that's where that's that should be her
but her accounts been deleted so far I
think we all know she's a fraud though
yeah but it's really gotta cool yeah
which is moving too that's and so on so
that's not makeup that's all digital
makeup and digital that's impressed you
can do this though some people are [ __ ]
you Joey yeah she's great
make any money off of it I'm just just
like over three hundred thousand
followers so I'm guessing three hundred
thousand but they stopped her account
right yeah well put it back on why would
they maybe I was doing that why stop her
account that's that's a really good
estrange you know what but the thing is
people can see and there might be a
company out there so and goes man we can
actually use that for our mark and
they're gonna hire I bet you get
together well you know that's the whole
thing with net neutrality right now
people are talking about it's like you
know people are crying about censorship
through these internet providers well
what about these Internet companies that
are doing censorship and the whole
argument is that they're a private
organization so it's not First Amendment
rights but it's like you re see YouTube
and and Twitter
censoring like certain people so it's
like where do we go with that it's like
the messages out I think it's blood in
the water they can't control it but
they're trying mm-hmm so why should her
account be a race cuz she's doing a
parody at some strange or so it's back
up but a different it's in Iran maybe
they maybe it's being censored by by the
state authorities the Instagram doesn't
abide by the yeah that doesn't Instagram
didn't work like yeah but I wonder if
they if Iran has their own way if she's
from Iran interesting I don't know
Iran has a very a lot of young people
who are very westernized and want all
the freedoms we have yeah yeah what else
you got chin whole underground god bless
him all right so this is going viral I
don't know if you guys see it as well
but something about Mariah Carey and the
way she's sitting or standing take a
look at it first
so it looks like she's can you can you
do that yourselves yeah it looks like
she's sitting she's sitting on something
so she's now check it out oh it's her oh
it's her heels they're so high that's
what it is okay why you can possibly
looks like you super quick why I know
about wound fields I have no idea but he
whirled me I wear them while I step what
I've never seen that ever the Y sucked
Sam's dick um no oh yeah yeah the
cheerleader yeah it's pretty amazing
yeah I heard her heels are literally
like this so you can sit down it's a
incline she's still doing the demo I'd
hit it
I love Mariah Carey I've loved her since
to start dude she's in my wheel cancer
hand wheel else hey Ross it's not small
it's a big girl yeah she every bit of
bitchin yeah tall I want a scrawny
[ __ ] I think you're Nick Cannon
should have a roast bomb huh I beat him
in tattoos oh honey what'd he get them
you beat him in comedy yeah it's
interesting dude you know teasing he
loves her man labs so much what else you
got when Tarantino Shaw Mike are you
doing impression so Quinn Tarantino you
guys are talking dude love to see Quinn
Tarantino I think that's great
he needs to do a superhero film like I
would love to see him do Ghost Rider
like his Styles awesome that'd be sick
he's [ __ ] all like I don't know what
let's get some little snow he's doing
the Manson story I love that dude he's
my favorite directory - yeah he feels
the best one is the best [ __ ] movie
incredible all his movies are good
they're also Shingo she's over goddamn
never made a bad movie you see the
hateful eight I loved it
I love dealing to me I loved it man
I love these doing us till dawn hateful
eight all fiction but magic doing a
superhero movie How Great Thou art far
be yeah I'd be sick for this superhero
movie I'm surprised every reached out to
him do Ghost Rider needs to come back I
leave he disclosure the movie
Quinn Tarantino Punisher the movie have
you liked though the Netflix [ __ ] yeah I
loved it I'm trying to stay home more
because I just am always trying to grind
and I'm trying to stay home and watch
more Netflix [ __ ] I just don't read a
book dude some Netflix so I've been
forced myself I love Wolverine it's like
finally they caught him I think before
they tried to make him too cute too
cartoonish yeah like yeah dude it's
enhanced man he's it's like nah dude
this guy is great gnarly yeah he's
gnarly I'd like to spit off a sabertooth
that'd be nice and then you know they're
doing venom and I think is that Hardy
the new or not yet Hardy Tom Hardy the
new party is yeah Tom Hardy is the man
oh man Ryan M son Phantom I feel like
that's what Vince Vaughn jumpin is the
man's man Vince Vaughn so you ever you
there when Vince Vaughn go to Comedy
Store he's he's at the Gracie Academy
all the time blogbeast he's training at
the Gracie Academy and Vaughn is so
lethal fast on stage it was unbelievable
really oh my god he does some stamp
there at the Wild West Comedy Tour I'm
sure he does you ever seen when he went
to Dublin's do you remember Dublin's
back they never saw yeah I used to do
Dublin's but all saw him do stand-up
their lethal fast yeah yeah well that's
why he's I mean that's right he's
killing it for the best
yeah yeah Tom Hardy for the so sick I
would also get he's the best dude that
guy's the man right now he might be the
best actor right now he's the Amy's a
man's man guys keen guys have something
they could flock to yep yeah I love him
Bob he would call him the Bryan Callen
of acting I've heard that I've heard
that twice work with him I'm an actor no
suggestion so for the audio listeners JJ
Abrams and Quentin Tarantino for the new
Star Trek movie and this Selena Gomez
who's like one of the most followed
Instagram Bieber sidechick she went she
put her account to private
recently I don't know baby new this is
you know I guess say something about
these I like we like to really pound on
these pop stars but they live in a world
I can't even understand I know they
they're so big and they they open
themselves to so much criticism and
harshness in it they become pinatas
we'll think about this Sam in there
Brian
mostly Sam though yeah mostly because
you have so much fame on Instagram so
think about the hate you get when you
post something whatever thing about the
hate I don't Runk we call it cool down
I'll just block people I'm like I'm
doing
I love blocking people I do freaked out
that shut up so now think about Selena
Gomez hold on the most followed person
on Instagram out of 16 years the most of
all pursuers it was she was about the
amount of hate she gets because I'll see
Kevin Hart post a picture I'll look at
some a few comments like how do you hate
on like what the [ __ ] why do you spend
time writing heat
well it's people that are just so
unhappy with their own lives and they
see people flourishing and it's their
own anger it's their way of lashing out
and that's probably why you suck because
you're the type person write a negative
comment did you read a Lady Gaga was
talking about basically her relationship
fell apart and she said something really
what with her man yeah and she goes she
said something to the effect of you know
before it broke up she oh they were
having problems she goes just try to
respect our privacy and maybe pull for
us a little bit because I know I seem
famous and I know everything seems great
but I'm also a regular person who just
really loves somebody and wants to make
the relationship work and you see her in
jeans with her armor illusion and she's
a regular [ __ ] person and moved my
limited experience with big people
famous people that that's you know yes
you're famous on stage but for the most
part your life is you know you still got
a great white gravity so gonna wings out
saying yeah man and boy oh boy the more
famous you get the more you need
normalcy and you need just at least one
person you can talk to you need people
in your LA I see people who blow up and
they they don't come around their old
crew anymore
and I see sometimes they're [ __ ]
miserable and I just go
well sometimes your I think your
relationships are like based on IMDB
credits man yeah and you like you gotta
have normal people in your life and
particularly people who know you back in
the day that that anchors you to
normalcy well I'll say you have to get
back to why you're doing that me Chris
until II and I were talking about the
rock and the rock seems to I don't know
how he finds the energy I don't know
where he finds the time let's let's go
through I'd like that you know I love
him I love the rock doesn't like the
pieces anyone who doesn't like yeah he's
in six years I don't need him he's in
ballers he's in movie after movie I was
to start out for the next three years
yeah and so then I but but deposited
after me a Chris for should be but
question Chris and I were asking like
what is like with that kind of thing
like like Chris was saying he's like
he's the biggest movie star in the world
like number two is way way over here but
what ultimately is the endgame like
what's driving you like what you're
making so much money you're doing so
much and on top of working out like your
puzzle Instagram videos it's 12 o'clock
at night we're still in the gym oh and
by the way he's also got kids right yes
so so the question becomes sometimes
like when you do that we Selena Gomez
you're the rock you can get caught up in
the work and that thing and churning out
product but what at the end of the day
are you doing what is the motivation god
what's the bottom line that yeah what
you can't get a bigger house right of
all the cars covered right get all the
closing and it's not like you grab the
private yeah you're not doing Gary's
your artistic stuff you doing the same
thing I was playing the badass yeah got
that covered
yeah all right what's the what's the
how's this head right how many of these
movies are you gonna do right I've seen
that buddy-buddy Tommy I'm all set on
that but movies maybe I'm wrong they
have a different vibe than the guys
before hundred percent ha two percent no
it may be so down the same character
same thing it's like it's no wrong like
Vaughn Dom or noisy more still like you
know he's way more dynamic he's in you
know all this [ __ ] be cool he's played a
great gag I he plays the badass but I'm
with Brian a certain point it's like all
right so you've signed on cuz you're the
most one man in Hollywood right now so
you signed on to a teen blockbusters
next
three years you're working non-stop yeah
it's kind of all the same thing - how
much money do you I just yeah I don't
know what was the craic do you want to
be home it's three yes eighteen eighteen
movies in three years now what are they
talking about him maybe 220 that puts
him [ __ ] does all these movies up to
Ben banks all these movies they are
they're coming out
governor runs for Sutton dudes yeah
maybe maybe he knows that I might vote
for him this this won't last forever no
matter what you do no matter how hard
you work it doesn't last forever
bring regards to what doesn't just the
level famous at you can't be at that
level for eternity no just the weight
goes maybe exactly as I'm hanging in the
mouth a couple people do that like Dane
Cook did that he banged out like ten
movies Kevin Hart did and they're hip
out yeah but you know it's like
sometimes it works something like that
maybe you realize that this isn't gonna
last forever
or maybe he wants to do something big
into 20 and he's banging out all these
movies now shiny commits to it the arms
for staying around and then like he'll
go try politics doesn't work by the time
that movie run is over of those eighteen
movies he can jump back in and so do
movies again you might be right it's
interesting idea was yesterday ambitious
man one more it's a happy story a
homeless guy saved two kids from a
burning house one was ten months one was
three years old and the grandfather left
the stove on and it caught fire to the
point he couldn't get to the kids
because the fire is there Jesus so this
homeless guy heard them screaming jumped
over the fence broke into the house and
saved a badass homeless guy that's the
homeless guy that's the guy - he's like
[ __ ] probably ex-military or some
[ __ ] like that guys it's pretty healthy
tatted up there but for the grace of God
go on yeah type move and even boom Sam
again where can they find your brother
chong kham sam tripoli all over the
instagram instagram everything and you
got that tour tour coming up Doody show
in Long Beach on December 22nd
got another comedy chaos on the 19th in
the main room
you know so just grinded grind and I'm
gonna be at Cobbs this weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday come see me it's gonna
be a great good when you play the Denver
club yeah if you need a feature okay I
don't feature for anybody but I'd love
to go up there and work and I just want
to get into that get you a second would
be sick what coming home whatever in
Denver Commerce yeah the best I'd like
to try to go up there and do it it's
like impossible in there February 2nd if
you need anybody I'll [ __ ] them
I'll [ __ ] do it do my hometown - yeah
Wow if you need somebody I love you I'll
even open it and then let somebody else
feature I don't get I just want you know
whatever you want I'm in Schaumburg the
weekend after December 14 15 16 as well
at the improv so come get your tickets
and then next week I'm in Syracuse
Wednesday night then Thursday people
Thursday through Saturday I'm in Buffalo
at the helium so one night Syracuse at
the funny bone then helium Thursday
through Saturday and then we just
announced January I want to say that
11th through the 13th I'm in Portland
helium in Portland and then the big one
January 19th I'm at the Wilbur theater
in Boston the night before UFC 220 and I
have a very special guest opening up for
me tickets at tea fat cake aam for Brian
and myself Sam we love you brother
love you guys thank you for having me on
yes is the fire the kid we're out